so Juliet you cast three of Annette's
first five films postcards from the edge
regarding Henry and The Grifters how did
it get on your radar and what was the
response from the directors like Stephen
Frears and Mike Nichols when you brought
her to their attention well I remember I
remember meeting you when you graduated
from a CT and then I saw coastal
disturbances and you know interesting
actually I remember in the meeting you
were rather serious probably you like in
a state of paralysis about your you know
first interviews in New York and so and
then going to see coastal disturbances
and you were so hilarious so far so good
and since oils of war too and so I was
casting dangerous liaison at this time
and Stephen Frears was the director and
I had a net in for the role that that
mark that Michelle Pfeiffer eventually
played and then Stephen wanted a net to
play a smaller role of a prostitute but
but it was fing shot in Europe and the
company wouldn't pay for her to go over
but anyway so then she would often did
Volvo which was also based on liaison
pleasures and then when the next year
all it was all so tight such a tight
period of time the next year
Stephen was doing The Grifters and I
said I said well what about Annette
Bening you know she'd be so great and
she reminds me so much of Gloria Grahame
and and so that was that was that
internet do you remember the first time
you went in for Juliet whether it was
for Mike Nichols or Stephen what was
that like I remember it was before that
because I had just come to New York I
just graduated from AC T as Juliet
mentioned which was my acting's
conservatory and I really I had been in
the regional theatre
and I mean it wasn't it I was 28 or or
at that point I was like 25 so I I mean
I'd auditioned before but I'd never been
to New York and I was very nervous and
we had a showcase presentation because
all the acting schools in the country
would come to a theater and you do your
scenes and then the theater would be
filled with casting directors and agents
and so I was going out and meeting
people for the very first time and so
Juliet couldn't remember well no
actually what happened was you what I
heard through the grapevine was that you
were interested in seeing me so that
alone of leagues I I guess I have a lead
presentation the the agents became more
interested in meeting with me just
because Juliet had expressed interest in
me so that's basically because you were
so kind Internet what was it like
meeting Mike Nichols on those movies
with Juliet do you remember that well I
think what I really want to say is that
as you can see from seeing Juliet and
I'm sure most of you here know her or no
of her work what you see is this
kindness and this considerate person
Norman said sensitivity when he was
talking about Lynne this incredible
humility and when you're an actor and
especially when you're first starting
out it's very hard to feel a sense of
your own dignity because you walk into
the room and of course there are other
people that look like you and you're
constantly auditioning and putting
yourself out there and it's very hard to
feel your own confidence and so
and you meet many casting directors
sadly who aren't very respectful and so
that's reinforced your own insecurity so
when I met Juliet she treated me with
such kindness and consideration and I
thought oh I thought the people at the
top would be the rudest and I thought oh
I see so the people that are the best
have the most grace and the most empathy
and that's what makes them great but I
didn't know that then